nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
nous vous emmenons aujourd'hui sur une
île connue pour ses glaciers ces volcans
ces aurores boréales l'Islande au delà
de ces paysages époustouflants ce pays
se distingue par son modèle démocratique
exemplaire depuis plus d'une décennie
l'Islande est numéro 1 du rapport sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
publiés par le Forum économique mondial
son parlement est le plus paritaire
d'Europe avec près de 48% de femmes
élues en 2021 mais que fait ce petit
pays de 376 000 habitants pour sortir
son épingle du jeu mérite-t-il sa
réputation de paradis de l'égalité femme
homme une enquête signée en Islande par
Mélina Huet de France 24
[Musique]
c'est une île d'à peine 380 lames qui a
accordé le droit de vote aux femmes en
le premier pays à avoir élu
démocratiquement une chef de l'État il y
a 40 ans déjà je le fais pour l'ENFI loi
pour l'égalité de salaire congés
parental exemplaire
une grève féministe en 1975 qui paralyse
le pays the world stops
une nation qui se pose en championne de
l'égalité des genres
[Musique]
mais ou rien n'est jamais acquis
de l'égalité femme homme
en Islande l'égalité des genres enseigne
dès le jardin d'enfants dans les années
80 malgré Olaf de T a inventé une
méthode pionnière dans le monde le
modèle cathly ce mot signifie briser les
tabous l'idée est né d'un constat
qu'elle a fait après des années passées
à enseigner en maternelle et en primaire
d'une certaine façon les garçons
prenaient plus de place que ce qu'on
attendait d'eux alors que les filles se
mettaient en retrait
exprimé plus d'hésitations
et j'ai une sorte de déclic mon dieu il
n'y a rien d'anormal chez mes filles
même si elle s'effacent il n'y a rien
d'anormal chez mes garçons même s'ils
prennent plus de place que je ne le
souhaiterais c'est le cadre qui est
mauvais
crée alors une école d'un genre nouveau
où elle invite les élèves à sortir de ce
fameux cadre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici garçon et fille sont séparés une
partie de la journée toutes les
activités généralement assignées à l'un
ou l'autre des groupes sont pratiqués de
manière indifférenciée
le football n'est ainsi plus seulement
une affaire de garçons prendre soin de
soi et des autres une tâche uniquement
dévoluer aux filles
[Musique]
est la directrice de cette école l'une
des 17 réparties sur tout le territoire
quand elle a découvert que les filles
restaient dans un coin de la cour de
récréation tandis que les garçons
l'occupaient entièrement elle a décidé
de la diviser équitablement en deux
espaces séparés par un simple chemin
[Musique]
les garçons sont venus nous voir car ils
avaient le sentiment qu'on leur avait
piqué leur espace
tandis que les filles nous ont demandé
si elle pouvait aller ici ou là
elle demandait la permission d'utiliser
le terrain qu'on leur avait donné
donc on a enseigné aux garçons à être
plus juste et aux filles à utiliser
l'espace
ici les enfants se mélangent à nouveau
en fin de journée et non aucune
difficulté à jouer ensemble alors que la
méthode qui atteli a été questionnée à
ses débuts Margret a été décorée par le
gouvernement islandais en 2007 pour son
innovation pédagogique comme pour les
résultats scolaires obtenus
nous sommes sans doute les seules écoles
et jardins d'enfants en Islande à avoir
des études qui confortent nos méthodes
on constate que les enfants qui viennent
ici sont plus ouvert d'esprit quand ils
grandissent en ce qui concerne les
stéréotypes de genre nos élèves sont
également meilleurs dans toutes les
matières
tes enfants plus ouverts avec moins d'a
priori de genre et des mères pour qui la
maternité n'est plus un frein à leur
carrière
après Reykjavik nous nous rendons à
selfosse à une heure de la capitale nous
y rencontrons une famille avec quatre
enfants
[Musique]
dès qu'il va prendre conscience que
c'est ce que je cuisine vous allez
entendre des petits bruits
quand David fait la cuisine astroos elle
jongle entre vie de famille et gestion
d'un commerce en ligne et engagement
politique
un quotidien qu'elle partage sur les
réseaux sociaux
j'ai enchaîné les grossesses depuis
décembre 2017 cela ne m'a jamais empêché
de faire les choses qui me sont chères
comme me présenter aux élections locales
dès la naissance du petit dernier Astro
c'est David se sont partagés leurs
congés parental pour qu'elle puisse
faire campagne un nom sujet pour ce papa
qui désire passer plus de temps avec ses
enfants
j'aimerais beaucoup être un père au
foyer
le bébé a droit à une année avec ses
parents divisé en deux six mois pour le
père six mois pour la mer
en 2021 le congé parental est passé de
10 à 12 mois avec 6 semaines
transférables à l'un ou l'autre des
parents
j'ai quelques amis qui vivent aux
États-Unis et il nous envie je peux le
comprendre
on est payé pour rester à la maison
mais ce qu'on perçoit est loin de ce
qu'on gagne en réalité
pourtant en Islande les indemnités sont
de 80% du salaire moyen du parent dans
une limite de 4200 euros par mois
une situation qui ferait pâlir d'envie
de nombreux autres Européens mais les
mœurs sont évoluées si vite que les
Islandais demandent encore davantage
d'efforts à leur gouvernants
on a besoin de plus d'options pour les
parents qu'il s'agisse de garderie de
jardin d'enfants ou bien de rester à la
maison et être payé pour cela c'est toi
en tant que parents qui doit pouvoir
décider
Astro c'est son parti de centre droit
militent au jour du même pour un congé
de 3 ans rémunéré
la politique un terrain que les familles
islandaises ont très tôt investi
le 24 octobre 1975 elles organisent la
première greffe féministe du pays un
raz-de-marée
pour obtenir davantage de droits 90 %
des femmes arrêtent de travailler que ce
soit au sein ou en dehors du foyer
résultat le pays entier se retrouve à
l'arrêt
parmi elles sigle et Duna
elle a alors 23 ans et participe à un
rassemblement de femmes dans le
nord-ouest du pays son souvenir de cette
journée historique est intacte
je me souviens très bien être rentré à
la maison après smeting il sentir
l'odeur de viande brûlée partout dans
les rues pourquoi parce que les hommes
essaient de préparer le dîner
cette grève inédite fait alors la une
des journaux internationaux et leur
permet d'obtenir rapidement le vote de
plusieurs lois
the write
le droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse qui n'existait pas jusqu'ici
on a aussi dirigé l'attention sur
l'importance des modes de garde
que pouvait bien faire les femmes si
elles devaient travailler en dehors de
la maison
il leur fallait des crèches
après la grève cette professeure
d'anthropologie confonde la liste des
femmes le premier parti féministe
islandais en 1983 elle est élue députée
sous cette étiquette là encore en
attirant les regards du monde entier
on était trois à être élu au Parlement
Christine
islandaises ont accompli un miracle
un parti fondé sur des idées féministes
n'avaient percé il y avait bien eu des
tentatives mais qui avait échoué
cela n'a fonctionné qu'en Islande
explique ce succès par l'histoire du
pays
150 ans durant lesquels les femmes ont
tenu le foyer tandis que leur mari
partait en mer pour pêcher
selon elle cela tient aussi au petit
nombre d'habitants que compte Lille
[Musique]
vous avez probablement de la famille où
étiez à l'école avec quelqu'un où est
ami avec une personne faisant partie
d'un mouvement féminisme ce qui vous
rend plus perméable à ses idées
dernière avancée majeure en 2018 quand
une loi impose l'égalité salariale
depuis cette date ce n'est plus aux
employés de démontrer qu'elles sont
lésées mais aux employeurs de prouver
qu'il ne les discriminent pas un modèle
pionnier qui a permis à l'Islande d'être
depuis 12 ans à la tête du Rapport
mondial sur l'égalité homme-femme pas de
quoi se réjouir pour autant selon la
professeure
être en haut de ce classement ça ne veut
pas dire être très haut pour autant
parce que le reste des pays est si
mauvais c'est vrai nous avons accompli
beaucoup mais c'est une chose d'avoir
une législation en vigueur et c'est
autre chose de l'avoir respecté on a
encore du le chemin un parcourir mais je
pense qu'on est sur la bonne voie pour
dans le futur
potentiellement atteindre l'égalité des
genres
car rien n'est jamais parfait même en
Islande
dans le pays 22% des femmes subissent
sous ont subi des violences domestiques
[Musique]
parfois on me demande mais comment se
fait-il que dans un paradis de l'égalité
comme l'Islande la violence de genre
existe encore et la réponse probable
c'est que ce n'est pas un paradis de
l'égalité des gens
est directrice d'un refuge destiné aux
femmes fuyant les violences fondées en
1982 il est l'un des plus vieux d'Europe
je pense que nous avons de bonnes lois
concernant les mesures d'éloignement
elles sont très simples quant à leur
fonctionnement mais elles ne sont pas
appliquées je crois qu'il est là le plus
gros problème en Islande
salut Sonia comment tu vas ça fait du
bien de te revoir ça fait un bail oui
depuis septembre sonia est une
survivante passée par le refuge avec ses
deux enfants aujourd'hui les rescapés
peuvent y vivre jusqu'à un an tu veux
que je te montre les appartements oui
avec plaisir
le loyer de ces logements est deux fois
inférieur au prix du marché
si à l'époque Sonia a pu rester au foyer
gratuitement son séjour s'est limité à
quelques semaines seulement
une parenthèse qui a pourtant tout
changé pour elle
[Musique]
ça m'a vraiment sauvé la vie cela permet
de couper les liens avec ton agresseur
son ancien mari lui a infligé 18 ans de
violences psychologiques et physiques
des abus traiter trop légèrement par la
justice selon elle
[Musique]
mon ex-mari a été condamné à 9 mois de
prison mais il est sorti au bout de
trois mois
je pense que si un inconnu m'avait
attaqué dans la rue de la façon dont mon
ex m'a agressé chez moi
il aurait probablement été condamné pour
tentative de meurtre ou un motif
similaire parce qu'il m'a battu si
violemment pas seulement avec ses mains
et ses pieds il m'a aussi frappé avec
une bouteille en verre et à menacer de
me jeter du balcon avant de me chasser
de l'appartement
donc pour moi ça
c'est une tentative de meurtre et rien
d'autre
Sonia se s'est malgré tout chanceux
d'avoir pu bénéficier d'une mesure
pionnière
peut maintenant pénétrer au domicile
et ils ont cette fenêtre de 24 heures
pour séparer les partenaires et guider
la victime des vecteurs
dans les 24 heures suivant un appel des
enquêteurs formés aux violences de genre
mais aussi des travailleurs sociaux ou
encore des agents de la Protection de
l'Enfance doivent se rendre au domicile
le but empêcher qu'un agresseur n'attire
à nouveau la victime sous son emprise et
que la fenêtre se referme pour de bon
cette mesure a d'abord été mise en place
localement par une ancienne avocate qui
a rejoint les forces de l'ordre
il y a deux ans s'écriture Bjork a été
nommée à la tête de la police nationale
on a 7 signalements par jour
concernant des viols ou des violences
domestiques
c'est 19% d'augmentation sur les seuls
trois premiers mois de l'année
des mauvais chiffres qui s'expliquent
selon elles paradoxalement par le succès
des campagnes de sensibilisation depuis
10 ans
son cheval de bataille que toutes les
plaintes donne lieu à un procès et que
les femmes soient accompagnées tout au
long de la procédure par une personne
dédiée à leur affaire
qui est vous n'avez pas à appeler une
structure qui va essayer de retrouver
votre dossier ou d'être ballotté d'un
côté à l'autre pour avoir des infos on
essaie simplement de faire les choses
différemment en écoutant nos clientes en
écoutant les gens que nous sommes censés
servir et en les écoutant nous pouvons
améliorer les choses
en 2022 une loi a été votée facilitant
le divorce pour les femmes victimes de
violences infligées par leur partenaire
si l'Islande fait figure de modèle ce
petit pays est encore aujourd'hui en
quête de perfection
voilà pour ce reportage signé Mélina est
envoyé spécial de France 24 en Islande
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter sur France 24
[Musique]